this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
we help you live your best life by being
healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful
financially triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the phone number
i'm ken coleman joined by john delony
and we are here together for you this
hour what do you want to talk about you
got some relationship issues that are
creating financial problems uh-oh
dr john is on call ready to go he got
some work issues
you just simply need to make some more
money
to get through those baby steps faster
i'm your guy let's get you a fatter
paycheck and eventually
help you do work that is absolutely
purposeful for you of course we're gonna
take your money questions it's just in
the middle of all this life stuff so
we're excited that you are with us dr
john you ready to go you got you got
hydrated there let's do it you're ready
let's do it let's go to john to start us
off in madison wisconsin john how can we
help
yeah hi can you hear me yes sir
um yeah all right i'll try to make this
quick so my wife and i we both make a
gross income of 144 000.
um we're about 80 000 in debt
and we have two paid for vehicles one is
a like nine thousand dollar um pretty
cheap vehicle and then the other one is
uh about 25 to 30 000
and so we're with
if we were to sell the jeep
we estimate that we could get out of
debt
uh by the end of this year and but if we
keep the jeep then that would kind of
add like an extra four months to pay it
off or to you know pay off all our debt
so
um just wondering if we should pull the
trigger and sell this thing and you know
get like sell for like 25 to 30 um
and then put that towards the debt and
get like a cheap like 7 000 vehicle um i
was wondering what you guys thought yeah
before we and john told you what he
thinks i'm curious which way were you
leaning at the start of this call you
called us i think you're leaning one way
or the other which way
yeah so actually one other thing i'll
add is we actually already bought
another vehicle
um for seven thousand dollars and um so
i
we're definitely more than just
things i feel like i feel like you
already made your decision and you were
asking us if you should return this
one more quick thing ken i've already
well the thing is like we love the jeep
and over the past couple of days we've
really been like do we really want to
sell this thing and then just buy it
again like you know two years down the
road or a year and a half down the road
because now that you've got like you
really love it now that you've got a
second car it becomes a thirty thousand
dollar toy yeah that with the debt you
have you can't afford
it doesn't make any sense at all i would
i agree with john my in
i was i that's what i would do because
here's what i know
there are more jeeps
yeah let me cast a little vision for you
for a second
what year is the jeep what color is it
tell me about it
it's a 2020 gray jeep cherokee
limited yeah oh please dude
you can find that all day long
down the road when you get where you
really want to go and here's what here's
what happened a bunch of people are
buying cars overpriced right now yeah
and then in 24 months
you're gonna be able to buy your jeep
back with cash for less than you sold it
yep i i agree i'd sell it at the top of
the market
yeah and that's what we that's actually
what triggered all this is because we
were like whoa
we can actually get more money for our
jeep than what we paid for it yes do it
stop talking about it today do it now
merry christmas we just we just made you
30 000 bucks on a free call how about
that that's the kind of value we're
creating dude nice call they're dropping
the roi out roi man i love that one free
call 30 000
there you go next yes vina
joins us next in cleveland ohio vienna
how can we help
hi
thank you guys for taking my call hope
everyone is okay
um
bear with me i am very nervous right now
you're doing great we're gonna take good
care i'm sitting next to ken coleman i'm
nervous too so go ahead yeah sure
that's a good thing you know i wasn't
even sure i was going to get through so
this must be meant to be
anyway um i am 53 years old i just
started um doing the
trying to do the baby steps i'm on the
30-day trial of um ramsay plus because i
did order the babysitter's millionaire
book
so i attended the first three classes uh
already
um a financial peace university
and i'm starting out with everything but
i am not quite sure
where do i begin i have some things that
i definitely need to pay off
uh my state tax irs tax i have
some loans that i had to take out um
just to try to make ends meet um
kind of like payday loans and i'm not
sure where to start out paying those
offers or should i start out you know
trading for the emergency fund
so vina you're brand new and we're so
thrilled you called like i couldn't be
more excited that you got through so i'm
glad you ordered the book and and we're
going to give you uh dave's total money
makeover at the end of this call for
free hey you know what else we're gonna
give her you got the 30-day trial we're
going to give you a year subscription to
ramsey plus fantastic
okay you're in it for a year i love
giving away dave's money so
yeah we were really gifted
uh but vina so here's the deal so this
is actually really simple um so you want
to do baby step one all right you're
gonna see this in total money makeover
and you're going to see this you get
involved
with ramsey plus so baby step one is a
thousand dollars you need to do
everything you can to get that a
thousand dollar emergency fund first
that's just a guard against anything
that might happen along this debt-free
journey okay then baby step two is you
take all of those debts so you begin to
list those out to us and so what we want
you to do it get it out on paper
computer however you feel comfortable
and we go smallest debt
okay right to largest and we're going to
attack that way don't care who you owe
money to yes except for the irs there's
one card for the irs i don't care what
the interest rates are your friends are
going to hear about this and say well
you need to pay off your highest
this is about psychology not about
dollars and cents
now if you're in
the irs they will take your soul so you
want to pay them i want to pay my plan i
want to pay my 20. what do you owe them
oh nine thousand dollars okay um i'm on
a payment plan yeah what is your income
87 000. oh yes so i want you to pay the
thousand dollar emergency fund and i
want the irs gone in three months
okay
okay
whatever you scratch claw whatever you
gotta do get the irs off your back and
you know what you're gonna do for the
first time in a long time you're gonna
sleep the whole night without waking up
in the middle tonight
yeah because right now it's just like oh
that's the only thing i think about is
all the stuff i have to pay that's right
and then you're going to look at that
list that's ken outlined for you you're
going to look at that list and you're
just going to
say
done with you done with you and you're
going to start with that one department
store that you still owe 42. and you're
going to move all the way up to some
student loan that you have or some
whatever is next okay don't yeah i got a
lot of those too there you go don't
overthink it don't beat it what's your
total debt number
it's over two hundred thousand okay my
goodness so you gotta include your house
[Music]
no i'm presently renting and actually
the first thing i need to do is get out
of that because my rent is entirely too
hard okay tell you what else here's what
i want you to do vina i want you to hold
on the line we're going to get you uh
free of charge we're giving away freeze
let's get to one of our counselors
they're going to work you through
what you're dealing with emotionally
obviously they'll
solidify the baby steps plan you're
gonna get total money makeover we got
you in ramsey plus work the plan
it will work if you stay with it if you
got to work two three jobs and you're
able physically do that less time to
worry about anything because you're
working so we're going to be free don't
move more ramsey show coming up
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show where we help you win
relationally professionally financially
with hope-filled practical steps that
you can take
so that you live the life that you want
to live i'm ken coleman joined by dr
john delony we are here taking your
calls it is a free call triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so obviously we take your money calls
but hey
what do you got going on john and i when
we're together i'll put this out there
if you're listening and you've got a
really difficult work situation i mean
it's nasty
uh john i reported earlier today on the
ken coleman show
uh 55 this is a national education
association
do you believe 55 of teachers i saw that
are planning to exit this is a dumpster
fire it's a crisis because these are the
men and women that care deeply about our
kids they're on the front line and those
exit are going to create even more of a
problem but hey you saw the uh they got
to do what they got to do the follow-up
was businesses are clamoring well of
course they are the higher so you've got
men and women who are organized good
communicators instructors have a heart
to instruct and do we love helping and
caring for people every business in the
planet it's like yes please how do you
not plug teachers in oh you want to work
just a normal shift and we'll double
your salary sure come on over oh yeah
with all the other
benefits you know you can actually do
your job the way that you want to but
anyway we digress but we're here to help
you get some family stuff going on
remember folks if if you've got a crappy
work situation you drag that stuff home
if if your family life is is going
bananas and it's awful you're dragging
that to work with you if you've got
money or money thinking everywhere too
money's entrenched in all of that right
so how can john and i help today listen
we're going to treat you with respect
um we've all done dumb
we don't judge we're here to help you
one phone call away
excuse me triple eight eight two five
five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five san antonio texas is where we go
next and joshua joins us there joshua
how can we help
all right um i'm i'm i'm almost done
paying off the debt i just have a couple
more debts and then and then i i'll be
debt free
so and
um good for you my first day yes uh
thank you
my first uh deaths that i have a
question about are these two medical
bills when i when i call them they say
that they can't find
they can't find it so that means so
yeah
there are two medical bills so do i just
like not worry about it and just and
just move on to the next one okay well
let's uh so we'll dive into that
so you're working the baby steps i hope
that's why you called the show and so if
we look at the debt snowball plan we go
the smallest debt first we pay that off
we take the payment you've been making
towards that we roll it you understand
that correct
yeah and you're doing that right
yeah so where are the medical loans in
your debt snowball are they up next are
they further down the list where are you
at right now
oh like this are they one of the the
smaller medical bills like they're
they're 45 they're 44 and 69 i already
called them okay and they just yeah so i
mean i mean i mean so just and they just
can't find them so they're literally
saying you called us about a 44 payment
and i think if i heard you correctly a
69 payment we can't find it in our
system anywhere
yeah so
my question was do i just not worry
about it so here's what i would do i
would take that money
and
do you have the money 69.44
um
quite honestly given how
absurd and chaotic and again i'm biased
because i've been dealing with this
recently
um billing systems are at hospitals i
would take that bill you're holding your
hand for 44 and i would just mail it and
at some point they'll circle back and
they'll send it to you or i'd put 120
bucks in an account and just let it sit
there and when they send you another
bill
if you owe them money they will follow
you to your grave so you can rest
assured that if you owe it they'll come
after you well and and john's right but
i would also say this if you've got
somebody on the phone it's worth a
second call and if we get a second
person to go say give me this enrollment
can't find this in the system i'd say
could you send me something on
letterhead an email something you're
writing saying that you no longer have
to pay this because we can't find it and
then i would stick it in i take the 150
put it on the next debt but john's right
okay until you get something in writing
you might as well assume that somewhere
somebody is going to come back for it
and this is not a lot of money yeah so i
think you got a couple great options
there appreciate the call young man and
you are on your way congratulations josh
you got to love you know hearing
somebody going man i'm getting after it
because he's getting after it and if if
if my advice changes there if it's a
thousand bucks
right i when it's a hundred bucks
i don't want to spend the same and i did
this i'm a cheapskate i'm going to get
the letter for 150. this is me the pot
talking to the kettle here i
punted on 150 charge it i was because i
was so i felt deceived yeah and i kept
trying to make my case and my wife's
like hey this 150 you please pay this i
was like no i'm just i'm digging my
heels in like i was some kind of
revolution
i was an idiot i should have paid for i
this the tax on my soul wasn't worth me
holding out and we end up having to pay
anyway so anyway oh i see what you're
saying but
in this situation yeah if somebody's
telling me i don't owe it
all right i'm in next there you go yeah
man life's too short to worry about that
all right let's go to los angeles
california next antonio is there antonio
how can we help
hey guys uh thanks for taking my call um
so the reason i was calling out i'm a
new listener um i'm 23 years old and
my parents have decided to
sell their house they've worked very
hard their whole life and move into an
investment property that they could
basically
live in rent free and that was pretty
much their plan ever since they
purchased it i'm just taking advantage
of the real estate market right now in
in our current house
so i want to know if i should move in
with them
as they want me to in our culture it's
pretty um
traditional i guess until you're married
to
move in with them
um or if i should start to sort of think
about budgeting myself and moving in
myself i'm guessing that since you're
calling
you are torn between your
cultural traditions and this gnawing
sense that i'm 23 24 i want my own place
am i right
yeah i mean i enjoy living with them
it's you know i love my family but i
just maybe it's just kind of natural for
me getting at this age and being in the
position i'm in to sort of start to
think about that sure they altered it
you answered it with a butt yeah the way
you just set that up i love my family
i've enjoyed living with them but it's
time there's the indicator yeah and and
up upending
long-standing cultural traditions are
hard and they take a lot of grace and
they talk a lot take a lot of gentleness
on both sides of those conversations but
um if you're ready to go then
you know what i mean i'm not gonna tell
you not to
are you ready to go and i don't mean
emotionally we've already determined
that you're ready but our financial are
you ready to go can you go now
yeah i mean you know i'm again i'm new
and i really never had to you know very
blessed i've really never had to worry
about things myself i mean myself
personally i mean
last year i brought home about 120 000
in history i'm expected to yeah yeah
this year i'm expected to
my goals are between 200 and 250 i'm in
commercial real estate so i don't i'm
not you know hourly i'm all on
commission
um don't mess with antonio are you what
are you what do you think their reaction
is going to be when you tell them
um i think you know i i don't know um
it's kind of been this is our childhood
home it's where i've lived my whole life
that we've decided to sell
um and it's just kind of been something
that
it hasn't been easy for all of us um but
i think that they would they're open to
me doing anything i want but they would
prefer for me to
move it with them and obviously continue
to save until i could purchase something
myself or to buy an investment property
that i could live in and
and hold for the future or something
like that that was the alternative
rather than jumping into something you
know right now even though i'm
financially ready maybe
i could yeah but here's what here's what
i hear uh john correct me i hear you're
still worried about disappointing mom
and dad that's it i don't think they're
going to jump up and down and get angry
i'm not hearing that am i right
no you're right yeah so they're not so
these are really wonderful people but
it's like you're it's like you're still
oh i don't want to disappoint mom and
dad and you know i mean so let me give
you an example uh
often
doing the right thing still hurts yeah
doing the right thing is still hard your
parents set up a plan years ago to get a
rental property that would one day
self-fund itself so they could live in
it and
that plan is coming to fruition and
you're still really sad about selling
your childhood home yeah both hand and
they raised a great guy he's killing it
he's got a great future he's ready to
fall for him to come move with them and
for you you're telling us the right
thing for you is to get your own place
you make six figures brother i would be
i would sign a apartment lease and i'd
move and live in an apartment i'd rent
for a year get my feet under me learn
how the world works and then think about
getting a house later on and antonio you
can always go back a couple nights a
week from mama's cooking that's right do
your laundry don't don't do your laundry
no just like 23. just cooking just the
cooking that's not holding on too long
that's one of the perks man just tell
mama you're gonna come by at least one
night a week for food hey
this is the ramsay show don't move
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back america i'm kevin coleman
he is dr john dolone this is the ramsey
show where we help you win in your life
we're helping you relationally we're
helping you financially we're helping
you professionally it's all intertwined
and we want to help you get ahead
practical hope coming to you
via a free phone call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five
two two five let's go to zach who joins
us out in sunny phoenix arizona
zack how can we help
hey i just had a quick question i am
currently working my way through college
i am probably going to graduate here
within the next six months to a year
depending on how summer classes line up
right now i am a stock broker with a
major brokerage firm and i i also work a
second job uh running deliveries for
laundromat and essentially have
you know being
working the job that i am at the
brokerage firm i
i want to help people with their
finances but the role that i'm in
there's no advice that we're allowed to
provide basically it's just placing
orders so sometimes
i feel like a bookie for people that
um
that are just looking to trade like
crazy and not necessarily actually
helping people understand their finance
and so how would you most like to help
people what's that dream gig where
you're helping people with their
finances what's that look like
well that's kind of what i'm why i'm
calling i mean i would really like to
have a job where you know i could sit
down and whenever somebody has a
question about their money i'm able to
help
guide them and and give them a plan
and have that as work rather than kind
of just taking orders all day long and
and tech issues and what not with the
website you don't need me to tell you
what those opportunities are but
certainly with ramsey solutions we have
our smart investor pros men and women
all around the country that are
financial advisors advisors on
retirement and investment planning and
all that does that sound like something
you want to do to sit down with a family
to sit down with an individual and get
their dreams get their goals all put
together come up with a strategy coach
them teach them so they understand how
to do it and they can win is that what
we're talking about
yeah
essentially that's exactly what i'm
looking for yeah so it's very simple so
if we look at the seven stages that i
teach for people to discover and do what
they are created to do
get clear stage one you're really clear
what you want to do and why you want to
do it stage two's get qualified so the
question is what do you need to do to
get qualified
do you know the answer well i probably
need good
uh it's one of two exams that i'll need
to take it depends on what the company
does and what the role they're looking
for but really there need to be probably
the certified financial planner or the
series 66. there you go so here's the
deal good answer so you start looking at
the company you just mentioned that
means you've got one in your head
you've got one kind of in your mind's
eye maybe it's the company you're with
and you're switching roles i don't know
but then you look at all other companies
and you start looking at those
opportunities to get on the ladder that
you want to be on and you start looking
at what the entry level are
do i have the base qualifications for
entry level are there a couple levels up
from entry level that i'm already
qualified for no i've got to take one of
those two exams that you mentioned find
out exactly what they're looking for and
go get qualified now while you're
getting qualified you're going to be in
stage three which is get connected and
so you're already a stock broker you've
got a lot of relationships so while
you're getting that certification that
you need and you're making connections
going hey i want to work at company xyz
i know you work over there who's the
hiring manager for this position and so
what you begin to do is is you begin to
make connections so that when you're
qualified
opportunities
may be waiting for you or they're not
too far off in the distant future does
that make sense
yes it does so when making connections
do you recommend using like linkedin or
trying to kind of cold call companies
and make connections that way not cold
you have a
i'll tell you something okay back in my
day okay i'm older than you when ken was
going to school uphill both ways naked
in the snow thank you kelly don't tell
everybody tilly's in the control room
going oh i know how old you are cold
calls were a thing it's creepy now yeah
and and you know okay so here's the deal
linkedin is is one option let me coach
you on linkedin
linkedin is great for
information i don't like it as the sole
connection here's what i mean go on
linkedin find all those connections but
instead of sending the linkedin email
which i find that nobody actually
answers why don't you then go wait i'm
going to try to find this person in real
life in the form of a phone call and
email connection from a mutual friend or
acquaintance so yes facebook instagram
wherever you at are on social media who
are you doing life with do you have
social groups are you going to a church
you know do you referee recklessly
you're a broker right now don't you have
people that you're making deals for
uh
most of the calls that i take are
cold calls coming in and it's it's
one-time interaction there's not really
relationships
i was thinking but with co-workers and
you're a student leverage that yeah tell
folks hey i'm a student about to
graduate i want to get into this can i
take you to coffee
and your parents
uncle larry don't forget uncle larry you
know the point is is you have all these
acquaintances and you have all these
close personal relationships
you got to get the word out to them hey
i'm looking to get on at company xyz
your company abc you know anybody over
there
and we begin to do the match process so
you got this young man
you got you are on your way
i love it it's that simple i love when
the guy goes yep i know what i got to do
you qualified so you know what it is go
get qualified go get go do it and while
you're getting qualified start making
connections yes here's the deal john
if i want to catch a train i go to the
train station right
so if i want to get a job in a certain
field i got to start hanging around
people that are doing that work
or start hanging out in places where you
know where i could shadow or i can meet
people that are doing that work we've
got to kind of
got to take out all the complexity here
this is about looking for people and
places and i'm going to butcher this
quote but it's from andrew huberman who
i just think the world of he's a
professor he's a medical school
professor at stanford
says that we often go to head problems
we try to solve them in our head you
can't do that if you're wondering and
thinking yeah wondering and thinking
isn't gonna you gotta go do go reach out
and sit down and cross with somebody and
screw it up have it be awkward have it
fail have it be goofy and learn better
next time but just sitting around going
i don't know i don't know go go you know
how to do a qualified go have coffee
john yeah i know this you're very social
yeah at some point you've played six
degrees of kevin bacon yes
this is all people have to do yep so
instead of kevin bacon we go i'm looking
to find this hiring manager who do i
know what are the connections that get
me to that hiring manager to where i get
a reference or somebody sends an email
or text going hey
let me tell you about this young man
zach sharp sharp stock broker finishing
up school getting his qualifications
right now i know him this is how i know
him growing up with it watch this kid
whatever it is and they get an
impression of you
all right long before or moments before
i don't care before you actually submit
the resume and go through the artificial
intelligence screening and all the stuff
that companies have and nothing
nothing in the world
feels better than having someone come
and say hey
i
think what you're doing a great job i
want to be like you someday i want to
sit in this heat someday would you teach
me
like how do you do that how do you get
there what's the job like
what's the relationship with your family
like
that man that's an incredible question
to be asked well you know you illustrate
something that we talk about all the
time because one of the questions we get
from folks is how do i connect with
somebody that is very successful in the
field i want to be and i don't have
anything to offer them and i always go
whoa whoa
what john just described folks is
actually tremendously valuable you made
them feel valuable thus you've offered
them value that's right yeah and who
doesn't love to give their opinion
especially when you're like you said
you're humble you hey look i'm i'm i'm
at the bottom yep i'm the grasshopper
you're yoda i want to be like you do
what you did i'm here to listen i'm not
here to ask you to do anything for me
other than what's the best way yeah to
get in what's the best way to move up
based on what
i need to watch out for yeah land mines
best part of your day the worst part of
your day
by the way
the advantage of that conversation
beyond connections
and and knowledge
is verification did you see what
somebody's been doing in a while and
actually loves it and they light up
across from you and you're going oh
they're lit up but i'm not lit up that's
a warning sign or if you're lit up you
go this is good news the number of folks
that said i really want to do that job
and i talk to them they're like yes it's
great you'll never see your wife and
kids again i think i want that job i
don't want that life and so let's steer
away right so it's you learn a lot by
just having human interaction with
people i love that so good he is dr john
delaney i am ken coleman and this is the
ramsey show more coming up right around
the corner
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right folks welcome back to the
ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined by dr
john delonie the phone number to jump in
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five taking your money questions
your relationship questions your work
questions
whatever you got we're here for you
today
uh you need to find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one on
online retailer of custom window
coverage you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best deal
i'll read the question john oh sorry
today's question comes from michelle
in kentucky while john checks his email
i'll
take care of you kind folks here you go
i'm working on my master's in public
administration with a 3-9 gpa
i value what i accomplished and would
like to maintain this gpa through my
remaining courses my career path is
teaching at a college level after after
so maintaining my academic performance
is crucial
my husband doesn't view the importance
of gpa the way i do and he wants me to
get a part-time job if i go to school
full-time without working i can finish
the degree in about eight months if i
work part-time while finishing the
degree it will take 14 months
imagining my gpa going down
while working and going to school at the
same time is beyond horrific to me
my husband says my future employer will
also look at my other qualifications so
i can afford to go down a bit in the gpa
scale
he believes my master's degree is just
another piece of paper how can i
convince my husband that my chosen
career field takes academic performances
seriously ouch
wow john a lot of emotion dripping off
of those
words this is a first of all before you
dive into this because this is clearly a
relationship question yes but can we
talk about the fact that there's an
assumption here
and i'm not taking sides here but
there's an assumption that the gpa has
to go down
yes i mean so the gpa is the proxy here
so just for
anyone you
you want your professor
to have made good grades if they're
gonna be a professor right absolutely i
want the pilot of my plane to have not
wrecked planes right does not have
crashed yeah so yes it if you want to be
a professor someday gpa matters
and the gpa has nothing to do with going
what's going on here i've got you've got
a husband that you don't believe values
what you want to do professionally
and you don't value his concerns he
wants you to contribute financially and
you want to study full-time so this the
the the career kin the gpa the part
those are all proxies to
a couple who is on two different pages
and this is one of those things that you
got to
hold the presses and you all got to sit
down and talk about where our
relationship so we got two fears here
john tell me if i'm wrong we've got
she's afraid of the gpa
going down if she works part-time yep
he's afraid if she goes full-time school
that their budget's going to be too
tight or that life is going to suck
unimaginably they have two fears
competing those are the two proxy fears
the two real fears are
either ah my wife's gonna be smarter
than me
my wife's going to
i don't want to lose her to graduate
school i
miss the old fun crazy us and now she's
studying all the time that's the fear
her fear is i don't want to my gpa to go
down i worked full time through all my
graduate school and i got a 4-0 in
graduate school not undergrad but in
grad school so that's not a true
statement here what is a true statement
is
your husband doesn't respect what you're
doing
you haven't um
told your husband this is why this is
important to me this is what i want to
do or maybe you have and he's blown you
off and so how can i convince my husband
that i'll just stop the answer that you
can't you can't convince somebody of
something else in fact we're in a world
now where if you put data on the table
it just further entrenches somebody in
their other positions no matter what
yeah if you say on twitter that the sun
is hot you'll have four people
reply instantly and go well that's
technically not true right and then
you'd say well here it's 118 degrees in
in my town right now and they'd go yeah
see that's the problem
it doesn't matter what you put on the
table i agree it's so all i'd say is
this isn't a conversation about data and
facts this is a conversation about
relationship yeah and this is you you
saying not how can i convince you
but let me tell you what i'm
experiencing right now i'm experiencing
a tug
a tension between what i want to do
and my husband not respecting what i
want to do yeah and the path it's going
to take me to get there sit down stay
vulnerable have a hard conversation and
just talk about your fears and your
dreams yeah and let's match them up yep
because this is not that hard to solve
no but appreciate the questions well it
is hard to solve if you get one of you
use an idiot and that happens a lot if
one of you is a bonehead or like
well of course
everything's hard to solve if you're an
idiot that's true john thank you for the
salient salient advice and wisdom i'll
be here all week yes let's go to john
now in philadelphia pennsylvania john
how can we help
hi guys good afternoon and um thank you
for taking my call i am a um
lifelong dave ramsey learner been been
since uh back in the total money
makeover days
um
came out of the city as a kid and went
to the military and uh went to college
afterwards and i have zero debt
at this point in my life uh i am a baby
steps millionaire
um very cool and i bought the book just
recently before christmas because i'm
reading it so that i can highlight it
and share it with my two children very
cool and um give that as a gift to them
you know i'm really excited about that
my question though today is um
i am as i said i'm debt free i'm
thinking my my youngest just started
college this year uh i have about
450 000 in cash at this point
i owe 185 000 on my home
i am
ready to transition my life in the next
two years my daughter is a junior in
college and moved my way down to florida
and i'm thinking about buying a condo in
florida now
but i'm wondering whether i should use
part of the cash that i have to pay off
my mortgage
at first even though i'm probably only
going to be in my house for about two
more years
i'm not sure which direction to go in
there
i wonder if you guys can give me some
advice how much is the house worth that
you're considering selling
200 000 400 okay
what's the hold up on the time why are
you waiting two years
um i want her to get through she wants
she's going to a local community college
for her first two years and then going
to the university of tampa for the last
two years
so once he transfers down to tampa i'll
be more comfortable being in that area
okay i just recently got licensed down
there as well my professional license
down there within the last few months so
i'm trying to get a little bit of
experience on my resume before i make
that move as well
all right so two things i'll put on the
table here number one
is
i think it's worth doing the math
the math being
what would if she finishes up this year
and you all sell the house in may
what would it cost to send her to
college one year versus
putting more money down in this current
house that you have are you actually
saving money when you look at your
entire financial picture
okay
and would it be
well ultimately in the long run would
you save more money if you sold your
current house and didn't dump 180 grand
into it you all moved down to florida if
you all going to move together and you
went ahead and moved her a year early
and got her out of community college and
did went that so that's one route okay
that's just a math problem
what i'll tell you is after working with
thousands and thousands of college
students over the years every college
student i meet has a four year plan
rarely does that plan work out that way
and so while you are thinking ahead okay
in a couple years she wants to
transition to tampa and
i would go ahead if i'm you and i'd pay
my house off yeah i would live in the
now as though this thing's gonna be
forever and if you end up doing it in
two years sell your house in in wherever
you are in philly and then move to
florida yep um that's what i would do
i'd go ahead and act as though cool
honey that's great let's make some plans
for it you've got license you're
starting to lean that way
but the chances of her saying well i met
somebody don't stay in philadelphia or
there's a great program and they're
offering a transfer scholarship for this
and or i want to go to nyu instead
whatever the thing is that happens so
much and so i live in the now john do
you believe that paying off the house
now gives you more options
not really i think i'm almost in of the
mindset that the market is so hot right
now my house value is probably it's up
there but quite honestly i think i think
that the best thing i could do right now
what i really wanted to do is sell my
house and rent something down closer to
the beach well then do the year or so
sell it pay it off so by selling it you
pay it off that's exactly right so i i
do that i think it's a great option i
love that option that's where you're
leaning and we like it
i love you do it yep and then you're
free and then you can buy when you want
to yeah i love that really good stuff
thank you so much for the call john hey
i want to thank our producer ben hill
and our associate producer and call
screener jenna sears and my colleague
john maloney but mostly want to thank
you america
we do the show for you and this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
we help you live your best life by being
healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john delaney we're here for you this
hour taking your questions triple eight
eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five
two two five randall is gonna start us
off this hour in cincinnati ohio home of
the super bowl bound bengals oh my
goodness taking the nfl by storm randall
how can we help
thanks for starting that way guys uh who
day by the way there it is i i knew we
had a shot at the who day and so you
just delivered beautifully sir
for sure for sure um so
i inherited a home for my mother who
passed away in december
for the full year prior to her passing
she had dementia
and both of my brothers are living in
that home they are not
receiving that inheritance via her will
one of them had taken advantage of her
in the last six months and completely
depleted 35 000 out of her bank account
and so i'm stuck
uh with this house and just not sure
what to do
not sure what direction to go with uh
with the brother who is stolen
uh and so i'm just kind of kind of
overwhelmed with it and i'd like to get
your guys advice yeah quick point of
clarification john
so randall do i understand that you
inherited the house in the will
you perfect yes okay and the two
brothers are living in it
correct okay yeah and so first i want to
say sorry about your mother's loss man
how did she pass away thank you
uh her heart stopped um i mean there
were complications from the dementia she
was getting pretty bad off but
um you know with various medications and
so on and and she just her heart
eventually just gave out okay
so what's your relationship like with
your brothers and it's an important
context for how i'm going to suggest you
move forward here
um
my oldest brother who is
not the the
guilty party
he i have a great relationship with him
i talk with him pretty frequently my
middle brother
it's very strained at the moment
okay as it should be because he stole 35
000 from your mother
his mom right and i'll go one step
further were both of these brothers
living with her during this time
yes yeah i i would suggest older
brothers got some
is complicit in this too
either through
not not stepping up or not saying hey no
chance you know what i mean not being
involved in this deal
yeah um so it was mainly my middle
brother who was who was doing most of
her caretaking um he was without work my
older brother was working
uh and and contributing as much as he
could but
for the most part it was my middle
brother who was doing that and he
i almost think that he feels like he was
owed that money because he was the one
doing all the the medical stuff and
taking her to appointments and and doing
all that yeah and you come to that
conclusion when all the kids sit down
and say here's how we're going to handle
the next six months of care and then at
month four and a half or five you sit
down have that meeting again and say
how's everybody doing and he just
decided he was gonna start billing his
mother for care he can be unemployed
living rent free billing mom by stealing
from her and that's the way addicts
that's the way thieves justify their
behavior
so there's a reason why your mom left
you this house and didn't split it up
amongst the boys is that right
yeah okay
so
the you've heard me say this before i'll
say it again it's not by your hand but
in your lap
you didn't cause this problem you're a
person of integrity integrity and
character and that's why your mom
trusted you with her home and
at this point you have to decide do i
want to be the landlord of a thief
and somebody's not paying attention to
mom or are you going to sell the house
tell them hey you guys got 30 days i'm
evicting you i'm selling this house and
i'm moving on with my life even if you
want to split up and give them some of
the money if you think that's the right
thing to do but i'm going to wash my
hands at this house and we're moving on
with it but i think that's your only
option right now
yeah i was coming to that conclusion my
my concern was you know do i what do i
do with my brother do i how do i give
him money
uh he's 51 and my oldest brother is 54.
it's time for you to stop taking care of
him
he's a yeah he's a big boy why would you
give him money instead of instead of
asking us well i mean if you should why
would you
yeah it's the
it's the heart issue i i just feel so
bad that he would be going out on the
street and i feel like i'm forced to
kick him on the street he's well robbed
your mom whoa
is there anything in the will
any kind of directive or suggestion from
your mom
that uh when she decided for you to take
care of the estate specifically the
house that you were supposed to sell it
and split the profits is there any
direction at all
no it was just for the goods within the
home that we were supposed to split the
house was so split the goods yeah
supposed to split the goods so here's
here's what the will said uh and this is
what we're doing sell this and here's
your proceed
if you want to give him your cut just
because you feel bad i mean this is more
my colleague's take but i'm just going
to common sense this isn't the counselor
approach but it's like you don't owe
this 51 year old brother
anything other than what the will
specifically lays out as it relates to
the goods inside the house outside of
that this is up to your discretion and
and you have to decide
am i going to
base my relationship
with my brother going forward
on me giving him more money
than that he doesn't actually deserve or
have any right to after he's already
stolen money i i just i don't think you
should lose any sleep over this at all
really the right thing and i say right
in a not in a moral ethical but the
right from a justice perspective is you
call the police
and you say that my this man stole 35
000 from my mother over the course of
six months
and i'd like it investigated
that's what justice would say
you sitting down and saying your free
ride at 51 is over and it's time for you
to get a job and against your own place
and if i guess i get the
the will says
this and i also get being a brother
saying if how much is this house worth
uh about 140. yeah so i can i can
imagine you holding 140 000 and watching
your brothers move out right and that'd
be hard and you'd think well they
deserve some of what well technically
you know his cut he ought to take the 35
000 out of his cut ooh i like that i was
giving you each 36 out of 35 000 and
five dollars and you can give your
brother one brother a five dollar bill
and the other brother thirty five grand
and high five him until him send him
another way but there is a reason here
while your mother left you this money
these problems don't come out of a
vacuum someone just doesn't decide to
take advantage of their dying mother has
he been like this for
a while
um really it's just developed over the
last six months to be honest with you
that i know of um from from bank records
why did she change no no i'm talking
about just a little bit squirrely a
little bit
out of work a little bit hey mom i need
to move back in a lot of 51 living with
mom
yeah i mean he's had various various
issues
he had a surgery he broke his ankle and
that eventually led to more
uh problems uh so he's had some medical
issues
within the last 10 years is why he's
went back with her okay um so
yeah
you're in the middle the situation got
dropped in your lap brother and i think
the right thing to do is to tell them
hey guys it's time to find a new place
i'm selling this house you can come up
with the split if you think that's
necessary i don't think it is especially
to the to the brother who stole from
your mom
um but you got to sleep well at night
so sorry for your loss ramble
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague john
deloney we're here for you this hour
triple eight eight two five
five two two five one of the most
important types of insurance you can
have is car insurance or motorcycle
insurance if that's your thing
most americans don't have enough car
insurance though and you might be one of
them if you get into an accident and you
don't have enough insurance you're gonna
have to pay for your own car repairs and
medical bills plus the other drivers car
repairs and
their medical bills and
their passengers medical bills that can
cost you
thousands of dollars or even worse you
could get sued so you've got to have the
right car insurance that's why we
created a network of endorsed local
providers or elps that means that these
licensed independent insurance agents do
things the ramsey way and they'll shop
around to get the best value on the
coverage you actually need and they'll
teach you how to understand what you're
actually getting so you are confident
that you are covered if you're ready to
work with an insurance agent who's
actually in your corner visit ramsey
solutions
dot com slash
auto to connect with a ramsey trusted
elp that website is ramsey solutions
dot com
slash
auto all right regina is up next in las
vegas nevada regina how can we help
i can hi dr d thank you for taking my
call sure um i'm gonna get right at it
i'm currently on baby step two um i've
been working on the debt snowball for
about five years
and uh as of this friday i was throwing
a curveball i was
served with paperwork from an attorney
that represented me in 2020
and basically he's basically calling my
note due i owe him 16 grand
so
in terms of my debt snowball i've i've
been up to three days trying to rework
it and trying to put priority in mind
my concern is and my dilemma is
part of my debt snowball was the initial
payment i made him on the unpacked out
so how do i rework this debt snowball so
i can see a light at the end of the
tunnel
how much were you paying him each month
well i initially took out a 401k loan
because i had to i had no choices it was
based on my daughter and child support
so i had to have an attorney i had to
have representation
so that was six thousand dollars i'm
still paying that back over a monthly
period on a payroll deduction basis
and then i have a car loan and a small
loan of a thousand dollars
and um
so i just don't know which way to turn
as far as prioritizing because
i've been doing it three different ways
and i still can't see the light so
you've been paying him monthly it's
coming out of your payroll i mean it's
coming out of your chat i actually know
that's right
yeah
did you did you have an agreement in
writing with him that you would pay him
out over a certain period of time
i actually had an agreement to pay him a
specific amount paid him that specific
amount
he said he would no longer represent me
after a certain amount of time because
of covid it extended extended extended
extended extended so because i find the
initial paperwork and everything covered
wise extended yes i owe him this amount
of money
okay so have you called him have you all
sat down and talked or does he think
usually you get demand letters because
you're delinquent in payments has he
been trying to connect with you and
you're avoiding him why is he sending
you why did why did he this is his his
first option
i think it's twofold
one because no attorney's gonna take me
on to represent against another attorney
and two because he wants his money now
i think it's just you know i'm sure he's
been
you know shafted by others
i just don't have it he knows very well
i don't have it i've contacted him twice
in the course of six months and said
listen we have this agreement this is
what i had i told you you told me
i just i i'm stuck and i don't know how
to look at this
outside of my own head so i'm just
hoping maybe i can get a fresh
perspective of do i rework this that
snowball and
sell my car because the car is the
biggest question mark in my mind well
how are you going to get to and from
work get to the grocery store uh uber or
lyft i work from home okay um
does your car get you out of your debt
with this attorney
no it'll get me about
if he wants 16 grand and he can settle
on that and not cause me any more grief
i have one commission check coming in
it'll probably knock out half of it
hold on so let's let's back up for a
second
your assumption that attorneys don't
want to sue other attorneys is a hundred
percent false i know several attorneys
that love
taking on crooked attorneys
they hate that people are out there
poisoning the profession
and they're happy too
i'm not saying he's poisoning but i'm
just saying
honestly i i don't feel he did an
equitable job in what he did to me okay
all right
differently so let's take the emotion
out of this then you have a 16 000 debt
that just got called
right
are you able to go get a loan for this
money and pay him
no that's that's where i'm having the
difficulty i'm tapped
like i said i took the original 401k
loan to give to him okay
so i mean now we're talking you know i
have no other resources i am just i'm a
single mom
i work three jobs i don't have any more
resources and i totally don't have any
more time i'm fried so regina he's
trying to scare you let's let's forget
about let's let's forget about him for a
moment because he actually knows you
don't have it
so if if we could let's just can how how
many lines do we have in the debt
snowball so we got 16 000 to the lawyer
what else do you have in your snowball
8 000 for the car and a 1200 small just
a small loan that i took out to cover
expenses because i knew some other stuff
was coming
okay and then what's on the 401k i mean
i know that's coming out but i still
want to know what that loan amount is
it's currently at 5 000. just just at 5
000. right so we had sixteen thousand a
lawyer eight thousand on the car five
thousand four one k loan twelve hundred
dollars in another loan is that it
correct okay
and um
you're telling me with your three jobs
you're absolutely maxed out you're
paying everything you can right now are
you putting money towards the 1200 on
the debt snowball you've been working
for five years that tells me you're not
making any progress
um well the problem is i have to hire an
attorney every two years my ex-husband
takes me back to court for more child
support
and this latest
2020 episode increased my child's
support by 25 so i'm i'm literally
reworking the budget from the babysitter
all right so every single year all right
so i'm trying to help you practically
very quickly here so
the car is worth how much i know you owe
eight what's the car i think i can get
eight for it i still think i can get
eight for it so that would wipe it out
totally so that's a massive chunk right
there mean here's what we teach
we teach working the debt snowball
you're in a situation where you've got a
lot of variables coming at you and i
think as far as this lawyer goes
i'm trying to channel dave right now and
i think you get tough with this guy and
go hey dude yeah so let me just be
honest with you you know i ain't got it
we can look at it you can come after me
all you want you're not gonna get a dime
until i can get healthy and i can get
set and i'm gonna take care of this um i
can work a payment plan
and give him a little bit he can get a
little bit of something and you can put
that in the snowball um on based on a
payment plan but that's that's all he
can get you can't let his bullying and
fear tactics make you make another poor
decision that's right so i'm sending him
a certified letter
that i'd make a copy of
and let him know here's you know that i
can't do this here's our original
agreement here's how it got it kicked it
got expanded through covet here's my
financial situation which you know by
the way i do not have 16 000 i've
already
loaned against my
uh 401k but
i will commit to paying you this much
over the next few months
and we will go from there
and
that's the best you can do if he wants
to sue you in court cool they're going
to put a judgment against you and you're
going to be in the same spot you're
going to have a 16 000 debt except it'll
be plus court cost or whatever right and
here's the thing i'm going to hook you
up with a free session with a financial
coach one of our coaches okay so i want
you to hang on the line and someone's
gonna walk through this specifically
with you but i want you to keep in mind
what ken just said
if you are out of options
i want you to rest in that
and i know that sounds bonkers
but there's nothing else
looking at these same numbers for three
nights in a row doesn't make new numbers
right it doesn't make a new there's not
a magic solution that you just it's not
a rubik's cube just gotta turn it right
away you gotta say you got a bully
coming after you for your money and
let's just be fair to him you owe him
this money
and now we got to figure out a plan to
get him paid back and so that means
you're going to he won't talk to you on
the phone like a grown up send him a
letter and make sure that he signs for
it i'm gonna say this i think you need a
win regina i'd sell the car if you can
truly get around and do what you got to
do via uber i'd do it i'd sell the car
now we got a 1200 loan we can attack
that then we'll figure out the payment
plan to the lawyer get some victories
our coach will help you this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation about your life
here on the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague
dr john deloney what a great song by the
way
i just watched the thing on him
yesterday did you yeah one of the
greatest learning to fly but i ain't got
wings oh good stuff tom petty the great
one hey uh it is uh resolution season
still and if you're like most people you
make resolutions on new year's day and
then you give up by valentine's day why
because you're trying to figure it out
on your own so if you decided to finally
take control of your money this year
don't do it alone get the support and
accountability you need by joining a
financial peace university class you'll
go through a proven money plan with
other people who help you stay motivated
right now there are hundreds of fpu
classes getting started both in person
and online so forget the lame
resolutions make 2022
the year you take control of your money
and don't do it alone find an fpu class
and get started for free
at ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's ramseysolutions.comfpu
uh let's go to dat who joins us in los
angeles california how can we help
hi thank you taking my call sure
um so
currently i just took a good job uh pay
cut um i changed positions and
part of what we were hoping would happen
didn't happen fully and so my rent's due
today i'm about 800 short i haven't
talked about landlords yet but i'm
looking for places to rent this cheaper
due to my paycard and
they're like 40 50 60 minutes away from
where i work currently
and
that's something i want to try to avoid
but i think i might have to do that but
is it worth that or should i sell my car
that's paid off for why'd you take your
why'd you have to take a pay cut
well um i was a driver for my boss and
i just didn't want to just do this 16
hour days anymore 18 hour days you know
it was salary so just until he was done
sometimes i've gone
18 hours three days in a row it was just
too much for me
because i also went to sales for for him
okay and did they promise you more money
on the sales side and it didn't come to
fruition for sales well it was uh we he
worked for another company and we were
again he wasn't putting on the sales
team on that company as well so i would
gain two salaries and two commissions to
equal back up to what i was being paid
and when he
was at the other company he was stepping
down to do something else and push me to
sales they kind of said no to everything
and just kicked him out so
that's where i'm stuck with that it was
kind of unfortunate he's helping me out
right now he's helping me set up a drop
shipping company you know funding with
some of that stuff okay back to my
original pay but which is how much
um 14 a week
1400 100 a week yeah okay and how short
are you right now of that
uh right now i'm only getting 500 a week
just because um another company is
supposed to cover the rest of it all
right so
first of all i'm really sorry about what
happened
i got to tell you that thing sounds so
screwy i i can't even process it i don't
like it at all and so my advice is we
want to quickly get out of this guy's
web i appreciate what you're saying that
he's trying to help you all that's
probably true
you're 900 short
of what you were making weekly in the
hottest job market we've ever seen in
america and you're in a huge city
so trying to take all this on john at
once i no i would not sell the car
that it's paid for because i think you
can sit down with your landlord and i'd
skip all the crazy
gymnastics we heard and go look i was
promised this it didn't happen i'm
working on this
i'm picking up a part-time job or two
i'm gonna be able to make up the rent
pretty darn quickly you're only 900
short per week this is hourly work you
can go bust it and get yourself stable
from the rent standpoint and then figure
out okay what's my next move what's my
long-term move this is what i want you
focused on
i'm in the industry i want to be in i
know but you can't eat yeah dude you're
broke
should i take it part-time as this this
was this was this one guy and then no
dude get away from this guy it's wacky
what industry are you in that you want
to be in driving
so you're in a can of a sales job right
now
yeah
okay so go find a more stable
situation in cannabis right now
you presented with an emergency my
friend and your emergency is your rents
due and you just took a huge cut but the
difference is you could go to a
reasonable uh landlord and go here's
what happened i'm busting it i'm gonna
get it to you and here's the other thing
when you first got a hint
that he you weren't gonna get this other
gig and it wasn't gonna pan out the fact
that you weren't at sonic's
door and then at uber's door that night
right it should it feel like you're just
caught like you want everything to just
happen for you and this is not the way
it works brother you got tired grinding
a job out and so you quit before you had
you you train transitions jobs
because you were exhausted i get that
but you didn't have uh another boat to
jump on you just jumped off the dock
into the water well my
my fiance just um was she thought she
was getting her first paycheck last week
so which would have made us cover rent
easily but she's not getting paid for
fire so in theory we can survive it out
you know just i just don't know well but
here's the deal long term i and i get it
brother and we're trying to help you
short term and long term okay so let me
encourage you
you're waiting on things to happen and
you need to make something make it
happen yes so
i listen no i don't want you to sell
your car
i think that would be disastrous yes and
no it doesn't make sense to move to an
apartment that's cheaper 50 miles away
from where you want to work because in
la that might as well be in oregon right
so let's just go okay okay so
hey let me go get a couple of side gigs
or one good side gig get my income back
up to where it was find a more permanent
opportunity in the field i want to be in
you got that working for you but don't
put that pressure on your fiance to help
with your rent don't do all this stuff
go make some money right now
right now go make some money get current
with the landlord take all that stress
off of yourself work those side gigs or
whatever you got to do keeping that 1400
a week minimum coming in
and then we make the permanent move do
you understand what i'm saying that's
the progress that we want you to go
through because it's going to make life
so much easier and is this guy the only
cannabis dude dealer in los angeles
legally no so i've just been with him
for a good amount of time and he's
really helped me out and taught me a lot
of things which is great
which is great and be thankful to him
but right now this guy's not a
dependable meal ticket true or false or
sh should i talk to him about it because
he says i need his help with stuff you
know how did anything just talk to him i
just don't wanna well hold on a second
dad
what why do you need his help him
handing you more money when you can go
make your own money
like why you don't need this dude to
bail you out you need a plan you need a
future you need to take care of the
present
do you understand what we're saying no
don't go to this guy and ask him for
more help he's not a dependable meal
ticket is that true or is that false
that's true as rage once said we're
trying to help you take your power back
right stop leaning on somebody else time
to go get it my brother
right and als also i still feel like i
still need to find a different place to
move because my rent's pretty high great
okay and find another place yeah but
anytime you are scrambling and desperate
to find a place to live that's when you
make goofy decisions
so get through this month
and then make a plan yeah
you're focusing on the next place to
rent when we got to pay what we already
owe so take care of that now
then we start thinking about the next do
you understand what i'm saying
yeah of course because listen man
we want you to be making decisions in
the best head space possible
and scrambling all the time and asking
for help and all this kind of stuff as
opposed to going and i like what john
said i mean take the power back or
whatever you said that was pretty
fantastic i said it wrong i'm sure no i
didn't come up with it that's who is
that that's from a great rock band but i
i it's easy to feel like you're stuck in
a trap and then a boss says this and
boss is gonna help you out here and then
help with this
man it it's time for you to stand up and
say all right i'm gonna go grind it out
cut the umbilical cord yeah i'm thinking
and it's not forever it's for four
months it's for five months and are you
going to be you thought you were tired
driving 16 hours a day you are going to
be unable to move your body so tired and
that's what you got to do right now and
i know that's not cool and it's not the
cultural ethos right now but that's
where you're at go grind it out man
and you're living in
one of the most expensive places on
planet earth right now trying to get
into this business maybe look at if it's
time to leave california or los angeles
and find a cheaper place to live and
still be in the business you want to be
[Music]
fascinating conversations i didn't think
that i would ever have 10 years ago my
health things have changed
i'm in the cannabis industry oh fabulous
oh i thought you just said
i thought you said you're in the
cannabis industry oh no no that's a joke
ken would make oh no even i'm not that
cheesy right all right folks don't move
more of the ramsey show coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
helping you win in your life win with
your money win with your relationships
when at work this is the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague dr
john dolone we're here for you this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the toll-free number
triple eight eight two five
five two two five portland oregon is
where we go next liz is there liz how
can we help
hi thank you for taking my call so i
think i'd describe this as like a
possibly a house divided but you tell me
our ongoing conversation is do we pay
off or not pay off the house or do we
sell or not sell i'm um open to both i
would love to pay off our home we
currently have a mortgage left of 305
305 000
um and all of our debt has been paid we
have nothing but the house left
um in the bank we have right around 300
so i would love to just see that go to
zero my husband's panicked when i say it
because like you mean you want us to
start at zero yes because i think we can
build that back up
so i don't know where to go with
that ongoing conversation but i know
there's days where it can be a little
bit more
heated than others
to say the least but at the same time i
would love to get an opinion so i can
use that uh in my ammunition at dinner
oh my gosh
before we get to ammunition uh this is a
relationship question i'll let the good
doctor weigh in but i do want to ask
you follow the baby steps yes
of course okay so when you say we've got
300 in the bank is that above and beyond
your emergency fund of three to six
months baby step three
it is okay so you wouldn't truly be
going to zero the three hundred thousand
you got in the bank
so so that's all i wanted to know
because when i heard go to zero i'm kind
of with the husband going hey we worked
hard on baby step three to get that
three to six months emergency fund which
if you're new to the program that's what
we teach baby step one is put a thousand
dollars in the bank uh for emergencies
then baby step two is to take all the
debts pay them off smallest to largest
give them a momentum then once all the
debt is paid off baby step three is the
three to six months of living expenses
which liz and her husband have so i
needed to get clarity okay what zeroing
out three hundred thousand meant to liz
i understand i understand
one of the whenever i'm talking to
somebody i always want to keep this this
one line in my head behavior is a
language
[Music]
so
your husband has decided that 300 000 in
cash just sitting there in the bank and
in this current economy it's actually
losing value
right is
giving him something so by him hoarding
300 000 in cash to have it at any moment
what is he trying to tell us what's he
telling you
not with his words with his actions it's
a good question
take a guess
just i think
i think i think it's just a little
rewind only because when we purchased
our current home it was the peak of 2006
and the economy crashed in 2008 and we
instantly lost 200 000 in equity
overnight as i know so many others did
yes but i think what happened now come
full you know gosh it's been a while um
we decided to hold on to the house we
got ourselves into it there was no way
we were going to just let go of the home
and walk away so we decided to stick to
it keep paying on it and now i mean the
house is worth upwards of 900. okay
so so let's just let's just look at this
through a trauma lens
a bear showed up at his cave back in
2006 or seven or eight
and that bear took two or three hundred
thousand dollars out of his soul out of
his equity
and despite what the market's doing and
what everyone's predicting and whatever
his body sees that bear again
right his body remembers the story and
the idea him pacing the house while
y'all were asleep wondering
what's the financial future of my family
is this it have i dug a hole that i can
never get us out of and of course it's a
teamwork thing i'm just
i've been him where i'm i take all the
blame and grief on myself
and i'm the one who's not sleeping he
remembers this story
and so this 300 thousand dollars is
providing him it's like a warm blanket
for him right now
and so i get that and
so it's both and i got to identify these
feelings i got to own reality this is
the truth it could all come down again
and
it's probably not going to
and if you have no house payment
it doesn't matter what the evaluation of
a house is until you sell it right so
this is the question i've got liz for
you and john here
i'm curious to know john
liz how are you talking about your
desire to pay this off is it are you
casting a vision like john alluded to
um and where you're kind of going hey if
we pay it off
this is what's going to happen this is
what's going to happen and this is
what's going to happen it's going to
allow us to do this is or are you just
going dead come on i want to get rid of
this thing we got the money i'm just
curious i'm not i don't want to project
how are you presenting your side because
you said this is an argument
well and it can be at times where we've
been married 17 years we have a strong
strong relationship so it will never be
anything to separate but at the same
time liz why do you hate your husband
i think to me i tell i i tell him the
emotional aspect for me is knowing that
we don't have to worry about that
mortgage any longer um
so that's yeah there's mine what about
what's his take on it
is he able to speak is he able to be
vulnerable back and say here's what i'm
scared of
of course and he understands that he
just said we work so hard to get here
and i would love to see us just hold on
especially with inflation and everything
else going on but at the same time his
his whole thing is we always bought
things at the peak and lost and why
would we do that again like in the sense
of why would we pay off the mortgage
currently instead of hold on to what we
have
hopeful hopefully hoping another bubble
occurs at some point and possibly invest
in some real estate
and so now you're talking so he wants to
hold 300 thousand dollars in cash just
in case something explodes and he can
buy the neighbor's house for pennies on
the dollar is that what he's thinking
right right that that's that's move made
dave very very wealthy it's a good move
but dave had no payments
and so that whole argument falls apart
if you still owe somebody money
what's your combined income
it's better than mine so our combined
together is right around 400 000. oh
goodness gracious lead with that liz
what do you do so i i did i did
well
i didn't hear i didn't hear 400. dude
well we didn't ask so here's what i
would do split the difference yell back
here's another thing you backed each
other into a corner where it's your way
or my way
what if you i like
200 000 on this house today and you kept
a hundred grand on top of your emergency
fund and you committed to him
the next six months is devoted to
getting another 200 grand back
and then we're gonna pay this house off
and we're gonna have 200 000 above our
emergency fund or 250 thousand dollars
and we're gonna have no house payment
then everybody wins but you guys have
backed each other into a corner where
it's you versus me and no relationship
works when it's you versus me yeah so
let's let's create let's create a third
way and and john i just want to mention
this i'd like them to try to take both
of their desires
and figure out how they both accomplish
it like let's combine visions it's like
we get competing visions that's right
and it's like okay how could he get what
he wants
some flexibility although i think you've
addressed a lot of this is fear but he
wants some flexibility to work really
hard for this big pile of cash i get it
yeah how do we get him his flexibility
but how do we also get you the peace of
mind
isn't that the conversation it is but
when you're working with someone who's
been traumatized i guess it's hard i
don't understand but you got to give it
a shot so
it sounds like in 2007 he walked out of
a restaurant and got smacked in the
mouth
and he's clinched that fence
fist for the last
15 years waiting for his shot to hit
somebody back
and he's looking at the high prices and
he's like okay this is my shot yeah
right you know liz quick question here
super practical we got to let you go but
i want to know yes or no have you sat
down and run the numbers and sat down
and said hey if we paid this off today
if we took the 300 boom it's gone with
our 400 000 combined income
we would have
no debt at all paid for house it's worth
900 grand plus
and then this is how quickly we could
build up investment money to do this
this and this in fact we could invest
right away right we're already doing 15
have you run those numbers and just
showed him a vision an alternative
of course well you guys are awesome
you're very disciplined you're in a
great situation it's it's so always
remember behavior is a language and
when you box yourself into a corner then
the only thing you can do when you back
yourself up against the wall you have to
come out swinging and nobody ever wins
when that happens yeah so let's decide
okay we're both backed up against the
wall let's let's find a third path
forward yeah and i like the idea of
splitting it up we'll pay off we'll pay
200 000 towards the house we'll keep 100
grand and we'll we'll go from there and
you could say pretty pretty pretty
pretty please
i don't know if it's gonna work probably
you don't think he's on tour today i
want to thank our producer james childs
our associate producer carl screamer
jenna sears my colleague dr john delonia
you america thank you for being with us
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcast
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professional
and peaceful financially triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number i'm ken coleman joined in studio
by my co-host and colleague
john deloney we're here for you this
hour what are your questions how can we
help you out
money relationships work they're all
intertwined and if you're suffering in
one area it affects the others and we're
here to help you triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
brennan
to start us off the shower in st louis
missouri brennan how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call you
bet
so i have a career change question so
currently right now i'm a teacher and i
teach woodworking and medals i also
coach at the high school that i teach at
very cool um with the content that i
teach being
basically industrial technology
i realized i could be making a lot more
with the skills that i have
and i do have a job offer on the table
to join a renovation company as a
project coordinator
and the question that i have is
whether or not i should leave teaching
and pursue this new career
because i guess i'm experiencing a lot
of i guess you could say guilt from
leading teaching because the hardest
thing about leaving it is the
relationships that i built with the kids
but i also want to make more money so
it's uh i'm in a tough place and just
want your guys advice sure what i want
to focus on first and i understand both
of those things i mean i get the pull
for money
and i understand the pull from the heart
with the kids and the other teachers and
as a coach all that
i think we have to focus on
do you love teaching
because i understand more money
um but but i i i i want you making a
decision
on leaving this particular
position
for something that's higher up the
ladder
as it relates to your goals and what you
want to do the work that you feel that
you were created to do and so i'm just
curious um
do you love teaching are you gonna get
over there in this
uh construction renovation job making
really good money and and not just miss
the kids but actually miss the
instruction and the coaching and
everything that goes into what you do
yeah
i do
enjoy teaching
i
like the aspect of teaching and
leadership
but i guess
teaching that i'm doing now the whole
teaching world is different than i
thought it was going to be three years
ago when i just graduated college
there's a lot that goes with public
school teaching now a lot of factors
that i'm just not as excited about as i
used to be sure does that make sense it
does and that's all i wanted to know
because here's the deal i don't want you
to just go after the paycheck
uh you're a guy who obviously you teach
woodworking and medals
yet you also coach
so
that's a big part of who you are and so
you just need to be aware that it's
possible and it may not happen it's
possible that if you go the route of
working with your head and your hands
the way that you do and you get in that
renovation world that you know you might
not just miss the kids you might miss
the instruction and the coaching so i
just want you to be clear on that
because the public school environment i
think it's pretty obvious it's not the
right environment for you right now
and so the question is do you take the
opportunity
um and to me again i'm never going to
tell somebody to just go chase a
paycheck
because i want my colleague to weigh in
here
uh because he's coached he's taught on
all levels
uh the paycheck wears off
that fat paycheck's pretty awesome for a
while oh yeah yeah but then it kind of
wears off we humans adapt pretty quickly
yeah so i want this to be a strategic
move not just a financial move yeah
here's a line that i think is important
to keep in your soul
you earn that money
and so if they're doubling or tripling
your income you're gonna earn that money
right and that's okay yeah you work it
and grind it and get it
awesome yeah it's just knowing that your
life's gonna change when i quit being a
high school teacher in a public giant
public school and a coach man i loved
that job um i transitioned out and took
another job loved it too i missed a lot
of it but also i made my way so it's
everyone's got to answer that
differently but i love that you said
that again don't chase don't do
something just for money unless you've
got like a i need in two years to pay
this thing off i'm gonna do this thing
short term and then we'll start those i
think those short terms are okay but
yeah don't chase a paycheck brother so
do you want to go work in project
management
yeah eventually i do and this would kind
of set me up for that i love
being around people and working on a
team and that's something i don't have
right now but eventually i do want to
get into
um project management more of a
leadership position with a construction
because the way i look at this is this
is the ladder you need to get on to
climb where you want to go do you
understand that
yeah i do it's just i guess it would be
bittersweet to leave the relationships
and the kids i knew that's where we're
coming so we got the counselor here
listen i'm going to give my two cents
worth but hand it to my colleague here i
hear this call a lot
especially from teachers who are leaving
the industry they form relationships
they form memories i get it um
but listen brennan you're not doing
those kids a disservice by you pursuing
what you want to do you're modeling it
for them and i don't think that you lose
those memories and i don't think that
necessarily you have to lose those
relationships yeah that would be my two
seconds how old are you
i'm 24. okay he's fresh is this your
first one of these hard transitions
yeah it is i i got this job at the at
high school not now right out of college
and so this is the first
career change i guess you'd say yeah so
whether you run into this with career
change with
um one day you're gonna have little ones
and you're gonna have to have a hard
conversation with your parents or the
in-laws or
in a dating relationship or with a
spouse someday
remember this
just because it's the right thing
doesn't mean it's going to be easy
it can be the right decision and still
break your heart and that doesn't make
it wrong that just means it's hard it
means you cared it means you invested a
lot means you love these kids and still
the right thing to do is this time for
me to transition
and there's no such thing as an easy
transition like this
and i would look at this as a blessing
they love you you love them you are
leaving with um joy in your heart and
sadness in your heart you're not leaving
with hey you get to get out of here pack
your bags and get out of here i hate you
i hate you
you get to leave with a tear in your eye
that's a gets a gift question brennan
how many of those young men or women
that you're working with in those
woodworking and metal classes are
probably going to go into the trades
they've even expressed that to you
um i'm in a pretty affluent district um
it looks like kids go to college but i
would say
probably
an eighth of my students actually will
then go into the trades okay so here's
an idea as you move into the trades keep
those relationships alive
dude i just want you to see that you
might be opening up doors for them
by what you're going to do for that
eighth that's right that wants to go
straight into the trades
you're not done with them you might give
them their first job yeah
say coach brennan we'll talk to you
about life in the trades we'll i'll get
coffee at a local coffee shop once a
month on a saturday and four or five of
them want to show up and talk to you
about it i mean
your your teaching will continue that's
it and you'll also teach some
knuckleheaded homeowner like me what
like how a cabinet works or whatever
else because that's just who you are
or you just get money from a knucklehead
like me who doesn't even want to know
how it works i just need it to work
there is that hey man brenda you got a
great future in front of you man thank
you for the call you're gonna do some
great stuff really really awesome stuff
love that young man hey
don't move
we have more of the ramsay show right
after this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman and my colleague is
john delaney we're here together for you
triple h
825-5225 if you've been trusting your
taxes to turbo tax for years you're not
the only one there the giant in the
online tax service industry but what you
may not realize is how they're screwing
you wow
tell them ken folks i gotta tell you
something i'm interrupting the read
because it's right there in front of me
and john i'm motoring through and i
didn't see that one coming not that
that's a bad word but boy that's kind of
exciting bring it kid whoever wrote this
copy it's hot bravo
i'm gonna say it again
they're screwing you
with their shady sales and marketing
tactics they lure you in with claims
that you can file for free when it's
anything but free for most people by the
time you enter all your info and you see
the real cost they've got you
and you pay more than you really have to
in other words they're screwing you have
i made that clear
what's even worse if you owe taxes they
smell blood in the water they circle
around you and sell you a loan or credit
card or some other junk product they'll
help you get your taxes filed but your
main bread and butter is putting you
their main bread and butter is putting
you in debt so we have a problem with
that of course so we took matters into
our own hands and launched ramsey smart
tax how is it different for starters you
get everything you need up front there
are no hidden fees no hidden agendas
just taxes
done right for less in other words we
don't
screw you over
go to ramseysolutions.com smart tax to
learn more and put your old tax software
on notice that's ramsey
solutions.com slash
smart tax favorite all-time read i'd
like to volunteer to do that one every
time hey and for what it's worth for
those of you listening i say this i'll
say it again i used ramsey i just
decided i'm gonna try it on my own last
year for taxes i sat down at my
kitchen bar area
knocked him out and i've already logged
back in to do them again this year it's
just a great clean simple program i'm so
proud of you it's awesome
i would use it if i would be allowed
anywhere near spreadsheets and numbers
no it makes it so easy
i know all right i'm going to do it are
you i'm going to do it it's free
what i'm going to do is i'm going to i'm
going to get it at the kitchen table and
i'm going to facetime you
i'm like john help me out walk me
through this i'm in are you in that'd be
the great all right it'll be fantastic
all right let's get to the phones triple
eight eight two five five two two five
noah is up in cincinnati ohio noah how
can we help
hey john and ken thanks for taking my
call so here's my situation last week my
car's transmission blew out on me
my car needs more work than what the car
is worth and it was a piece of junk
anyway so long story short i need to
purchase a new vehicle my wife and i
have um a difference in ideas about what
the correct
purchasing choice is the unfortunate
truth of this current car market is that
it really kind of feels like no matter
what you do you just get screwed if
that's the word we're using in this
segment i feel like we have a theme
going on here
yeah it's just it's tough it's it's
really tough so anyway so what's your
what's your decision and what's your
wife so you get two different opinions
here what let's let's list these out so
my wife and i just had a baby and
currently her car she has a car she has
a four-door car
and so she feels like we should buy
either like a crossover sedan or a
crossover or an suv or maybe a minivan
something of that nature my belief is
that we can make do
with
a car a sedan sedans are cheaper
four-door car versus a crossover with
just one kid we want more kids
eventually but that's down the road
um and you know of course they're more
affordable um of course my wife and i
follow the baby steps we're in baby step
four five and six so we don't borrow
money on cars good for you um so
so my attitude my attitude is in light
of the fact
that this is the way it is my feeling is
i should just buy like a three or four
thousand dollar piece of junk
fight the bullet accept the fact that
it's going to need repairs and then
maybe one day down the road when we have
you know us our second child we can buy
a bigger car a newer car a nicer car
um my wife thinks that we can buy a
certified pre-owned something that's
like three to six years old that's got
low miles and how much whenever i
look online
and see what those cars are selling for
it makes me want to vomit yeah but
forget the vomit can you do you have it
do you have it in your emergency fund
i've got it um i've also got it to buy a
new car i don't want to spun but i know
that
dave ramsey's attitude is you know you
don't buy new cars until your net worth
how much do you have how much do you
have set aside
for the car
like
like 25
um wait a second dude i gotta bring my
colleague in here this is getting to be
a major marital issue
you're telling me first baby got it it
doesn't well i don't know but you're
talking about a three to four thousand
dollar piece of junk was one of his
options that he won with
that wouldn't be the car that wouldn't
be the car i'd be driving my baby around
and we would take her you know
my wife's car oh i didn't catch it there
you go so i
if you're asking me what i would care i
would do exactly what you just proposed
is
or let me just tell you what we did in
my house like this here it is uh my wife
had we had two little kids and her and
the two little kids drove around in an
would be a now a 12 year old prius for
five years six years
and it wasn't big it wasn't nice it's it
was safe it got them to where they
needed to go it actually was nice it was
fine great gas mileage you got got to
and from and now my son is about 17 feet
tall
and so we just now
upgraded i'm in a different financial
situation we're in a different all the
situations were different
so if i'm you i'm not going to let a 22
pound
little being
suggest i need to buy a land tank if i
don't have that kind of money right now
what is your wife driving right now
she drives a nissan sentra it's a it's a
what they call a compact car it's a 2016
it's kind of got high miles for the
years but it gets 127 000.
i but it's safe and in good condition
but my point is is that you've got the
money set aside so
yeah not a new car but if you want to
get a minivan for her that's going to
have a little bit more dependability and
you can get it in that price range
there's no right or wrong here but are
you buying a piece of junk for you sure
yeah yeah if that's what you want to do
but that way it wasn't presented that
way it was that my wife wants a
a new thing minivan
i'll show her yeah
she doesn't want to drive the baby
around in a nissan center that's what
you presented right that's the issue
right well she doesn't want to drive the
baby around anything oh it's clear
that's awesome
it's your concern that you want to hang
on to this money for a year two years
and hope that the
car
buying frenzy that's going on slows down
is that what you're wanting to do just
buy yourself some time
yeah and also i just i hate cars full
disclosure i hate cars
they you just lose you just lose and i
get zero joy out of them there are means
to an end and quite frankly my
hard-earned cash there's other things i
want to spend it on yeah okay okay now
all right so okay practically you solved
your own problem yeah so let me just ask
you this how much is the nissan center
that your wife is driving what's it
worth right now
i don't know eight grand it's got a lot
of miles yeah but it listens on it's
sold at private sale eight grand
probably right so let me throw something
at you just to consider
it's never going to be worth that much
again
so if you were to take that right you
can drive a piece of crap it's obvious
you want to she don't care
fine but take the nissan center there's
eight
and if you can get a minivan for 17 and
you got 25 put away you still have a
whole big chunk of cash but you get your
wife a little bit more dependable
minivan suv and you both win and you're
not spending all the money
just an option i'm not telling you i
think that's a brilliant idea you know
it actually is to be honest with you
because i've been married 24 years
i'm trying to give you some marriage
advice on top of everything else you can
drive a turd on wheels
a used car and you drive the sentra and
just call it good if you know that car
and trust that car there's that option
too
i'm trying to save his car basically
you're kind of telling me that there's a
couple of decent options in light of the
situation
most couples back themselves into a
corner with these kind of fights and
then it becomes you versus me and nobody
wins when that happens and so anytime
you feel like we don't
i only have this option and she's only
got that option that's when you say okay
no one's gonna win here let's come up
with a couple a third a fourth and a
fifth option here which we gave you some
fantastic options
that make for a happier wife
which i'm told
leads to a happier life
i say make her drive the cintra you
can't make her do anything but i say
drive this intro that's just me
wow
bad marriage advice from the
relationship guru just my take you guys
gotta get her a decent little minivan
make everybody happy all right
we'll figure it out during the break
don't you move more ramsay show coming
up
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right folks welcome back to the
ramsay show i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague dr john deloney we're taking
your calls
about relationships your work your money
it's all intertwined we want to help you
win the phone number is free and if
you're just on the edge you're going i i
need to call
today's the day call triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to orange county california
derrick is there derek how can we help
yeah hey karen hey john thanks for
taking my call you bet what's up um
yeah so so i've got a
question about rental property
my brother and i we own the rental
property we bought it in 2007.
um we made it to the great recession
it's cash flowing now
we just refinanced it a few months ago
so the goal is you know pay it off and
as quickly as possible but the the
question is whether i should sell it
or or or keep it um
it's sort of there's a couple dynamics
to it the uh
my brother has really been the most
reliable person this was sort of
uh inheritance
and when my dad passed we
very young so we kicked it into
real estate because we don't know so
we actually bought two condos so we sold
one but
um so my brother hasn't been the most
reliable um
so he so so it's it's making it
complicated to to pay the thing off as
quickly as possible in other words he
needs the monthly
money but it's compounded because you
give him the money and he doesn't really
doesn't really do much you know she's
just just kind of loafing around
um you know so so i
i'm torn and i've been torn for years i
don't know what to do on one hand it's
it's you know a connection between him
and i and my father's passing and sort
of a legacy thing and on the other hand
it's you know my financial future that
is at risk here but so so i really don't
know what to do um let me ask you a
couple quick questions yeah um thank you
for the call and this is this is tough
um how much is it spitting off in cash
flow
after you pay fba is cash
cash flow after everything is cash
flowing so about 700 a month so 700 a
month and are you guys splitting that
350 to him yeah 350 to you
how much how much do you owe on it
well right now it's about 196 000. how
much is it worth
it's worth about 450 000 now
okay
is
is there some type of uh
legal binding agreement that you guys
have to agree on selling this or is this
just straight up relationally we gotta
agree on this and i mean who who's in
charge or is it split
it's split
um there's no formal documents there's
no llc nothing like that it's actually
all in my name
um it's not technically in his name we
can get him on title but i'm nervous
because of the liabilities well let me
just say this if it's in your name
you're in charge
i'm in charge correct you can list it if
you want i'm not saying that's what
we're recommending right now but right
now it's in your
name john yeah let's back out of the
house thing let's put the house thing
aside here here's the two things that
i'm hearing
number one
this is your tether to your father good
man
correct
yep he took care of y'all
yeah how old were you when he passed
away
uh 22
how old are you now
uh 40.
you still miss him don't you
yeah oh yeah yeah
so
you're gonna have to
open your hands at some point whether
it's today whether it's 20 years and
you're gonna have to let your dad be
free and go
and that doesn't diminish his role in
raising you and making you the man that
you are providing you an example
providing you financials none of that
stuff goes away
but you're hanging on to him as hard as
you can and you've
you have buried him inside this house
the second thing is
is let's look at your brother you don't
want to do you love your brother you
don't want to do business anymore with
him
and this tether between the two of you
is choking you both out
and so the best thing you can do for
your relationship with your brother is
stop being business partners with your
brother
i love my wife to the moon and back we
are never going to run a business
together we run a household together we
are not going to be in business together
because our marriage would end shortly
thereafter
right so you can love him and care for
him and say you're a knucklehead with
the way you live and whatever and decide
to not be his business partner
and now we come to the house do you see
how we're going in order here one is
about grieving one is about
man i'm just 40. you're 38 we've grown
apart we're not business we just do life
different it's time for us to separate
us business partners i'm gonna put this
house up you can buy it from me i might
even sell it to you at a discount but
i'm selling the house
and then you can take your cut and be on
your way and i think that's the simplest
way forward
how does that sound when i lay it out
like that
it makes sense
um you know part of this this house has
been part of i don't own a home you know
where i live in southern california i'm
working towards that and
selling it would
give me a chance at owning my own you
know living in my own my own home so
it sounds logical um but we laid out
like that but
and it's okay to wrestle with this
there's a weight in your soul mate we
can still hear you hanging on and that's
okay
what's going on what are you feeling
after john laid that out but we're also
looking at the financial case
yeah well you guys just nailed it i mean
it's the it's the tether and it's the
tether between not just my father but my
brother
as well so it's there's a whole lot of
family drama beyond
but is your brother is your brother
going to financially benefit from this
yeah yeah he would he would
big time i know i knew the answer i'm
trying to get you to realize that this
is gonna benefit your brother
way more through a sale of the home
than the 350 he's getting per month
you're gonna hand him a couple of
hundred thousand dollars
so
you shouldn't have any kind of guilt or
feeling bad about this
i'm actually going to go back i don't
think it's unhealthy john will correct
me and i can handle if he needs to
correct me but i think i'd almost ask
what would dad want me to do yeah dad
dad did this what's the best way to
steward your dads what would dad want
you to do for you what do you think
answer that
uh
well you would you would just want to
you know make sure that we're
you know he would want he would want
what's best for us i mean i don't know
another way to put it okay so so i i
agree so listen you guys aren't making
much money on this i'm not trying to
knock what's going on but when you said
hey ken it's cash flow positive
it's barely
350 bucks a month for both of you
you got debt on it there's risk involved
expenses you want to be a homeowner you
both have a chance to take something
your dad did for you
and still remain healthy and both walk
away i think you got to present it as
this is a win for you bro and it's a win
for me
and i think you just got to make that
decision i think you know what's right
but i don't know what you're afraid of
with the brother
but
you got to decide are you going to
resent your brother
or are you going to disappoint him if
this is something that disappoints him
but you believe it's right that's his
choice that's his that's on him but if
you don't do this and bro you're 40
you're gonna look up and be 50. you may
resent your brother
and so that's on you do you see what i'm
saying derek here's what i want you to
do i want you to
get some quiet time about an hour by
yourself maybe two
i don't want you to get a notebook it
can be a 99 notebook from walmart or you
can get some fancy schmancy thing off
the internets i don't care
and i want you to
write your dad a letter and i wanted to
start like this dear dad
i love you and it's time for me to let
you go
and i want you to write to your dad and
let him know all of the things that
about the man you've become in the 18
years since he passed
the things you're excited for about your
future the things that he has missed and
you're sad that he missed him
the ways you're carrying his legacy on
financially with your
kids with your spouse all this i want
you to talk to him
and then at the end i want you to tell
him i love you and it's time for me to
let you go and he's still going to be
with you
but it's time for you to take let him
out of that house
and then you can start doing the making
the hard calls the business calls the
the nuts and bolts calls that you gotta
make because your dad's gonna be with
you forever my brother whether you own
that house or not
derek you said it
dad would want us to do what is best for
us
be okay with answering the question what
is best for me yeah with this awesome
property that he
bestowed on you both
hey man sorry
about the stickiness but thank you so
much for being
vulnerable with us and uh calling us
the best is yet to be don't move more
ramsay's show more of your calls coming
right up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my co-host and
colleague
dr john doloni
today's scripture first corinthians 13
6-7 love does not delight in evil but
rejoices with the truth it always
protects always trusts always hopes
always perseveres
today's quote from the legend booker t
washington if you want to lift yourself
up
lift up someone else
boy that would be a great mantra for
social media these days everybody wants
to tear somebody down to lift ourselves
up what a great word that is wow good
stuff there
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number let's go to boston
massachusetts next where raymond is on
the line raymond how can we help
hi there
um honored to be here um
i
just lost my job yesterday unfortunately
uh so sorry
yeah thank you so whatever
oh what happened um it's it's really
really a long story there was a
couple
uh people losing their jobs
basically upper upper management was
trying to cut down
for several reasons and you know i had
something i just had like a mistake that
was like a technical error
uh like
on my um
you know
log or whatever on the system from the
game in a month ago
it was the tps report one yeah you
didn't put the cover sheet on the tps
report you didn't want to say it now
management's
so basically a bunch of nonsense it's
not a major stain right
yeah you know still emotionally it feels
a little tough
but um
you know i'm i'm a hard-working guy i
mean i've worked uh
some really uh tough jobs for someone
who's only 23.
how can we help you
oh yeah let me get to my question so
i
uh have a couple things a couple options
to
sell that
things to sell that i was hoping
uh i could just say out loud and you can
maybe help me make sense of it sure
one of them
is my car i have a uh
so also i have three thousand dollars
credit card debt
um and i'm in school full time as well
um
and i have a car and i was thinking of
maybe uh giving up the car because i
really don't use it to drive anywhere
farther than i can walk or i could uh
take a bike how much do you owe on
i actually don't owe it i i you know i
took your advice uh i read uh
total money makeover two years ago and
uh try to live by that example got a
four thousand dollar uh 2010 uh toyota
corolla
what can you get for it right now
uh
well
forgive me i could get four thousand
dollars for right now for sure when i
got it it was like uh 5 000. that's fine
all right so that 4000 would wipe out
the credit card debt and you'd still
have a thousand dollars
as an emergency fund right
yeah and and that would be a great help
uh just until i can get a new job and
let's let's back out 30 000 feet do you
have a place to live
yeah you got you got enough money saved
up for food for the next few weeks
uh that's the other thing is uh
i was uh
i spent a lot of money on christmas okay
uh
thinking i had it
well and that i was going to work uh
extra hours over the years do you have
money for do you have money for food
i have money for food
and
uh that's pretty much it coming out okay
let's just all right we gotta we gotta
solve right now with some stability okay
so you're a full-time student how many
hours were you working a week and what
were you making per hour
i was making 17.50 an hour i was working
uh 24 hours a week
okay
so so were you struggling with that or
was that
you know besides you've got the credit
card you spent too much on christmas but
that's going to take care of stability
for you you're going to be able to focus
on being a student if we can replace
24 hours a week minimum at 17.50 an hour
would that make you pretty stable pretty
safe pretty calm
you know it was a little tough but i'm
also
a photographer and i'm also starting to
make a little bit more money off of that
i have two photo shoots planned where
i'm going to make a couple uh bucks this
month which means
you could have more time which means you
could make more and be even more stable
yeah see where i'm going we need to get
you stable you're a full-time student
that's what you're focused on
um
i like selling the car because that gets
rid of that credit card debt and that
takes all of that junk and i want you to
cut the credit card up you read total
money makeover you know what we believe
on that
if you truly don't need the car
i'm knocking that out and i'm getting
rid of the credit card debt i got a
thousand dollars that's a that's a
padding of an emergency fund and dude
you're in boston area
i mean dude
i mean listen
walmart
amazon target these are all paying
somewhere between 15 to 17 an hour i'm
just giving you some big names here
you can go bust it right now and take
care of the stability issue and not be
stressed that's what you do you're a
student what are you going to school for
uh exercise and health science i lost
like 50 pounds over the past uh year i
don't know
an exercise so i'm real passionate about
it way to go i'm actually i'm sitting in
front of the gym in my car right now
yeah we love it okay so you're a guy
that can do hard things you can set a a
goal and accomplish things that other
people go no you can't
this is just one of those and don't blow
by this ken and i have talked about this
in other shows
getting fired is akin to losing somebody
when it comes to the level of grief
don't blow by it don't let your friends
be like oh it's cool bro they sucked no
you spend a moment saying this hurts
and it's not tough or not masculine
you gotta sit down and say this hurts
it's hard somebody looked at you and
said i would rather you not be here
that's that hurts i don't care what
happened it hurts definitely definitely
i'm feeling that thank you listen own it
feel it own it and then be about what
comes next right and then go set up
another goal you lost 50 that's way
harder than finding a good job in boston
my brother oh the 50 pounds
and you know what else john i i believe
that if he takes care of the work he
goes and gets a job and he keeps the
income coming in he's gonna allow him to
heal faster absolutely if you're
panicked yeah
while you're hurting it's like a it's
like getting left right it's like mike
tyson hitting you from both sides so and
i would even go there before you sell
this car i want you to give yourself one
week of looking for a job
see what happens okay see if they're
gonna land a 25 an hour job
and see if you can land a job or two
that you can get back and forth do with
this car right so i don't you're
panicked you're exhausted you got
punched in the mouth yesterday and it's
easy for us to look at our budget and go
okay what's the first arm i can co i'm
gonna cut my left arm off because i
write right handed and so it may be that
in seven days when the smoke clears i'm
gonna go ahead and sell this car and get
out of debt and clear it
but i really want you to see if you can
reach out and find another job you got
to get some money you got to get some
security you got to get some food money
and some rent money and like ken said a
little win and a little win somebody
looking in the eye shaking your hand
saying yes sir we want you that's going
to feel good yeah right
yeah and listen raymond there's no shame
in what you're going to do man you're a
college student on his way to doing some
incredible work
go get the best stinking thing that pays
you 15 17 18 19 20 an hour go do that
there's honor in that and i'm with john
i don't mind waiting a week but i want
him to nail that credit card get that
credit card out of your life he can go
buy another four thousand dollar card
down the line that's true i just want
you out of that credit card debt i want
you to stop using that as something to
fall back on
and you'll get the job
you pay the credit card off
dude and now you're off and running
now you're now you're actually going all
right i'm gonna put a big emergency fund
together right so what does three to six
months look like for a college student
let's get that number in there you know
and so now you're coming out of school
and you're on your way you've got a
bright future and all this garbage and
stresses out of your life and and and
the best is yet to be for you what's
your what's your total weight loss goal
brother
oh uh i went from 185 to 135. whoa
good
yeah so are you are you parked in there
my goal
i'm parked i'm i'm good now i'm actually
for the first time my life trying to uh
gain some weight and work hard to just
put on the muscles so i'm gonna say
maybe
raymond go get it brother he's like
flyweight bantamweight he's just going
down exactly right wow good stuff hey
thank you for the call raymond sorry
that happened to you but don't let it
hold you down john deloney always fun to
be with you pal thank you so much i want
to thank our producer ben hill our
associate producer and call screener
jenna sears and you america this is your
show this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you